Steve Kerr the Golden State head coach
joining us Continental Tire Coaches
Corner
coach we were talking I don't know if
you saw where LeBron was reciting a
two-minute span during the Celtics Cavs
and everybody was going oh my gosh you
know he's able to recall what happened
in a two minute stretch is that normal
with great athletes that they have sort
of that photographic memory of moments
in a game that they can recall the
slightest detail yeah that didn't
surprise me at all
I've seen a lot of guys do that or to me
even just talking to players you know
after a game we'll go over a sequence
and you know staff 4kd dream on those
guys it's the same way they they just
kind of remember everything and they see
everything and I think it is a pretty
common trait were you able to do that
yeah I can still remember plays like
I'll watch tape now you know we've
watched our three Houston games that we
played in the regular season and I'll
see stuff from January and it was like
oh yeah I remember these next three
plays it's it's just you know you get
obsessed with something and you and you
remember it and it just I don't know
it's you know I can't really remember
you know what I had for breakfast some
days but I can remember you know the
shot James Harden took against us in
January so it's selective memory I can
but do you remember your playing days
like if I said give me like you have
sequential moments there when you hit a
big shot uh yeah yeah I mean I I can
remember some of that I mean not you
know and not everything but there are
certain key key moments that you think
back to you and like I'll never forget
you know MJ's last game in Chicago and
you know he's he lays the ball in down
three and then he steals it from Malone
the next play and then he hits the
game-winner you know to win the
championship
I'll remember that sequence the rest of
my life do you remember the huddle and
before any of that I actually did it so
Jordan has the steal on Malone and but
there's no timeout called is there no
there was no timeout
yeah I think there was a time out before
he laid it in we were we were down three
and I think there was a timeout
and Phil called for a clear-out of
Michael spread the floor knowing that
since we were up three they were gonna
guard the three-point line and that's
when Michael laid it in and then went
back down the other way and stole the
ball from Malone in the post and then
there was still no time out and and then
he hit the shot when he you know we got
past Brian Russell Brian Russell yeah
you remember that better than I do yeah
but the main thing I remember is I had
the offensive rebound I had inside
position on Stockton I was getting ready
to go tip dunk I'm watching the video
Steve I don't see that you were gonna
run I run baseline I got a half step
past Dakin yeah and I tried to time it
up but you know ball went in Michael got
the glory but why why wasn't he
double-teamed you know it happens fast
out there it really does and and you
know when you have shooters out there
it's just like Toronto and Cleveland
last last week you know everybody said
why didn't Toronto double LeBron well
kind of happened out of the backcourt
and guys like LeBron Michael they're so
fast so athletic that it's not quite
that simple just to go double and Brian
Russell was all over him and obviously
Michael you know used that offhand and
you know and shoved him a little bit and
got free but it's it's kind of scary too
as a player like when you're defending
your guy and your guys a good shooter
you just don't want to you know you're
just a little reluctant to run off and
leave him entirely and so I think
there's some of that involved in a lot
of these plays that you see yeah I'm
just trying to figure that out I'm
watching Boston looks like Brad Stevens
who's saying hey we're not letting
LeBron beat us which I mean it sounds
simplistic it's not that easy but they
made it look at a little bit easier than
than it should why don't Worr teams just
say LeBron we're gonna double-team you
and you know if Kyle Korver Tristan
Thompson have great Knights then so be
it
well I think Cleveland generally is that
its best when it's making threes you
know and so what you want to do is try
to try to limit
LeBron and then take away the threes and
and I didn't see the game we were on the
plane to Houston and so I haven't seen
any of it but okay you know I know that
when we've played Cleveland in the past
you know if Kyle Korver hits three or
four threes you know those are killers
yeah that's what gets their team going
and what Boston is able to do they're
the best defense in the league they're
able to take away a lot of stuff because
they're so versatile you know they've
got multiple athletes multiple wings who
can switch and guard the post you know
Al Horford is a great modern-day center
you can protect the rim but still get
out to to play guards kind of like
draymond Green and and and that's what
it takes these days and that's why we've
been lucky here we've got a lot of
versatility defensively on our team too
James Harden's kind of in that short
list now of unstoppable now and maybe
that's maybe that's a little too heavy
of praise to put on him but I mean he's
getting into that rarefied air Stephen
the last 30 years of these guys that
it's just how much they're going to get
on you right right you know you put
Jordan in there and Kobe in there I
guess LeBrons in there I don't know who
else goes under the unstoppable in the
last 25 years
Allen Iverson is he in there right sure
sure yeah and I think it's accentuated
now because of the way the game is
played
you know the three-point shot is so much
more prominent it's funny you look back
to like the mid 80s you watch a Lakers
Celtics game and the game is played in
this small little radius you know and
now I mean you got you got guys on
Houston spread out 30 feet from the hoop
so you know it's it's made it more
difficult to run one-on-one players and
and the rules have changed too you know
back then you could hand check more and
now you can't really touch guys and and
you have to honor the 3-point shooting
so the the modern game is perfectly
suited for a great one-on-one player
like hardened and Houston's done a
really good job of putting the pieces
around him to make it even more
difficult to help on him and that's why
they've they've been so good last couple
of years where would you put your
starting five historically last 25 years
I don't know I mean it's so hard to to
compare eras because of what I just
talked about with
with the rule changes there just are
many big dominant centers anymore so you
know the modern game is much more about
just throwing a bunch of six eight guys
out there together and letting him
switch everything and they all handled
they'll shoot and it's but if you think
about that if you go back to the the
Bulls teams in the mid 90s there were
there were nights where we started Kukoc
it Center and we had Ron Harper MJ
Scottie Pippen Rodman and Kukoc and talk
about a lineup that would have thrived
in today's game you know that was that
was the most like versatile skilled
lineup of its time and and and I think
as far as is actually similar you know
if you think about it when you got the
multiple playmakers and shooters and and
the big guys who can switch you know
like like Rodman could I mean draymond
is as good as anybody Kevin Durant's
really good with that
Iguodala so you got you got versatility
and multiple playmakers that's the name
of the game these days and and you look
at the teams that are still still
playing they've all got that but who
would give you the most trouble you
talked about the Bulls perimeter you
know harpin and Pippen and Mike were so
long out there Rodman you know was great
as you know you know great defender as
well you know the bad boy Pistons were
such a deep team with Hall of Fame
guards there we were talking about this
last week with Reggie Miller and we're
just saying which team would give you
know had they had the ability to guard
this or play against this Golden State
team hmm anybody come up well yeah I
mean I think those Bulls teams would be
best suited just because of because of
what I mentioned just the versatility
you got it you had to be able to get out
to the perimeter and you know you've got
to be able to get out and guard Steph
Curry in a pick-and-roll 30 feet from
the hoop to guard us you know and that's
a pretty hard thing to do and the game
was so different back then the bad boys
were unbelievable defensively but you
know as lambier going to get out to to
guard Steph Curry on the perimeter of
course they would have let him just maul
him and like nothing to the ground at
six times so different era true
true we also I JJ reddick on and I said
the the prettiest the best jump shot in
the NBA and you know who he picked I'll
bet he'd pick Clay County as he did yeah
he said there's no wasted energy no
wasted movement no so do you see have a
better if you were teaching jump shot
would you teach clay or Steph I would
teach clay I think there's more more
rhythm and sort of natural hand-eye
coordination and Steph's and when Steph
shoots a lot more kind of off the
dribble
leaning drifting his hand-eye
coordination is so amazing that he can
do things that most people can't but
clay I agree with JJ clays jump shot
reminds me remember the old iron Byron
the golf golf simulator yeah like that's
that's clay he's iron buyers like every
shot is exactly the same over and over
and over again and it's it is it's it's
perfect
fundamentally like you just can't you
can't get any better than than him in
terms of form and and you know just
eliminating a wasted motion extra
movement it's just automatic it's just
boom boom over and over and over again
it's just amazing to watch but but how
does he get out of Los Angeles
how does he end up at Washington State
if you've got a guy who has as good a
form and can and has size to get his
jumper off how did he fall through the
cracks I don't know it's not amazing yes
it really is but but you know that it
happens more often than you then you
think you know a lot of the other guys
in the league maybe weren't that heavily
recruited and but clay you would think
you know UCLA or zona you'd think those
schools would have been all over him but
then again I didn't see him play in high
school you know maybe he was a little
bit of a late bloomer but I'll tell you
that the thing that's most amazing about
clay is the fact that he guards at the
other end he's so well on the ball and
and then you know on offense he's turned
into Reggie Miller Rip Hamilton in terms
of running off screens so he just never
gets tired he's in an amazing amazing
condition and he's just a big strong to
guard who can play all day and it's it's
really an
weapon for us you were talking about
Rodman and and we see draymond Green and
I see a little bit of Rodman he's he's a
better all-around player than Dennis but
you know trying to frustrate you Dennis
it felt like had a method to his madness
is there a concern that you know maybe
that's what we're seeing is more of
drayman's personality whereas Rodman was
trying to play a role when he was trying
to get into your head no no this is this
is exactly what you need if you want to
win championships you have to have guys
like draymond and I think what dream on
has done the last couple years is he's
he's learned how to corral his emotion
you know he obviously had the issues a
couple years ago when he got suspended
in the playoffs so far I guess through
ten playoff games he's got one Technic
or maybe one technical one flagrant you
know nothing major he's in no no danger
of you know of anything in terms of a
suspension and I think he you know you
he has to play on the edge but he's got
to be able to walk that line and that's
what he's figured out how to do you got
a Rodman story that you can tell me I
got a ton that I can't tell you
do you have one no well let's see I mean
yeah there are there are a lot
sorry trying to pick apart the ones that
I'm not allowed to see when he was
dating Madonna did you guys talk to him
about that
no no didn't really ask him much about
when he was wearing a dress did yet like
come on did not ask him about the dress
I think the thing with with Dennis that
people would be surprised to know is
that most of it was an act you know he
was he's actually a very shy quiet
person and practice he hardly ever said
anything he revered Michael and Phil and
was it was just a you know I got a good
good worker when he'd come to practice
and then he'd he'd go and all kinds of
hell would break loose did you turn on
the TV you'd be like what the hell's
going on
I need to come back to practice and just
be quiet and you know do is do his work
and go home again and do something else
crazy well that time that I was out with
him at the crowbar and then came in
remember that I came in the next morning
and you and judge Buller going out with
Dennis Dennis is running around like a
madman and I'm like seeing like you know
five different heads when I'm looking
out there and I think Dennis had an
unbelievably bounds that night or
something crazy but just boundless
energy and anytime you went up to the
bar you had to do a kamikaze shot so he
was at the bar and then he would he had
a Chicago police shirt on and then he
would say he kept calling me Sager he go
do a shot anytime you want to get a beer
you had to do a shot so thank God there
was no social media back then Steve
thank God and then he'd give any get 23
boards oh my god unbelievable
did he ever guard Jordan in practice a
little bit a little bit you know he'd
get switched on to him or something and
and usually it was more fun than
anything Michael would laugh and and you
know they had kind of smile and and but
it was fun to watch and Scottie same
thing you know Scottie and Michael going
at it and practice was not easy that
would be real though watching those two
go at it where that was real that was
real the old dentist from the Piston
days would have been great but not not
the one with the Bulls hey I know you
got to go and have fun tonight thanks
for joining us great to talk to you
again Steve I appreciate it dad take
care thanks Steve Kerr Continental Tire
coaches corner Continental Tire
exclusive tire of Major League Soccer
since 2010 Continental Tire has been
getting fans to and from the match with
confidence with the traction performance
and comfort fans demand in a tire
Continental Tire you can tweet them
using the hashtag ode to soccer
Continental Tire proud supported the Dan
Patrick show for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]